foreign
[Music]
just one of the best dinners I've had in
L.A probably the best meal I've had in
La yeah fear steak feel these nuts in
your mouth
uh no it actually was it's called feel
steak so good the bread at the start
it's like a tray of fresh bread and then
they have meat drippings that's one of
the things you put on the bread
I've never had that before what even is
that come sweat beef what's dripping off
this beef you get any prezis uh there
any presents yes I did when you get some
running clothes a Nicola truck a Nicola
Truck Yeah
Nikola stock actually yeah yeah sucks
yeah
um
congratulations you lost money for your
birthday dude that's like I got my whole
family
like ethereum like three years ago
and I was like just trust me this is
gonna end this of course it's like worth
nothing now
my mom was like I think mine's worth
like 20 bucks now or something like that
and then she sold it when she was here
wow like sick Mom thanks just cashing
out on that gift card yeah thanks for
having faith Thanksgiving I cooked uh a
sweet potato casserole like one of the
real like dessert like ones it's just
like yeah it's like a sweet little treat
but you eat it as part of the main I
like the snark snark
what does that mean I learned to snerk a
little uh let's just turn around that's
when you eat a little sweet treat in the
main you're snarking
got a little dessert chicken yeah
exactly or vice versa yep yeah if you
eat chicken for dessert it's snarking
that's so gross dude you have a big ass
steaks like could we interested in
dessert I'm gonna take the half chicken
oh you're snarking tonight huh that's
just bodybuilders yeah yeah exactly I
would like to have a whole chicken after
this steak speaking of which did you see
the liver King
exploded
yeah do you see him the remnants was
left of them
no what happened oh he's his his uh
blood tests got leaked someone who
worked I get I don't know the full story
but uh Derek
I don't know I think they worked for
like the testing company or something
leaked his emails and they're all like
his signature and it's like thanks liver
King
and it's his blood tests and like the a
full
um panel of all the [ __ ] that he's on
and apparently it's [ __ ] crazy how
much how much [ __ ] he's taking this guy
was taking 132
000 of HGH a year the ridiculous thing
is he was taking three different HGH
boosters and they still weren't raising
the levels of igf what HGH H HGH makes
your liver excrete I don't know how this
is going to affect liver King's Legacy
I mean
did he have a legacy I mean the whole
thing is he's got a company right he's
got a supplement company yeah this is
his steroid regimen Sue said I've been
working out for he wrote this in an
email
yeah to someone and then they leaked it
yeah I've been working out for 35 years
I know how to eat train and recover
uh but as I've reached my mid-40s it's
getting harder
and the back fat [ __ ] sucks or
something I've recently started taking
omnitrope
blah blah blah but he said for instance
here's what I'm currently taking one igf
CJC
ibutamorin omnitrop test cyp Deca
Winstrol that's all different [ __ ] I
know Deca I know d-ball I know Trend
I take all of them do you yeah
really yeah you don't see it
no you don't see it no dude are you sure
are you working out yeah it's so funny
to take all that [ __ ] and not do
anything yeah and that's a lot of people
is it yeah they take that [ __ ] and they
just
for what then the emotional
benefits no I think some people think
they just jam it in and then they work
out a little and then they but I'm
saying let it be funny to just do that
and then code all day oh yeah yeah
you'd probably build a code for a day
straight your fingers will get ripped as
[ __ ] yeah you probably feel [ __ ] good
dude yeah so he's a fraud
oh no I would have thought dude the
whole time who would have thought
liver King yeah man he's not real
well I hope you saved that money pal
that's how it always goes man
those dudes
yeah
always
how was your Thanksgiving
um my Thanksgiving
was good it was simple
just a few family members over uh we did
two it was a long weekend okay we did a
family we did a family yeah we hosted
yeah that's that's rough we had uh the
family one which was great then we had a
little friends giving which was also
great I also was basically sick on
Thanksgiving oh that's a bummer it was
ass huh I basically slept until dinner
like sick or like like sick ah yeah
that's a bummer I thought you might have
done a k Flip or something no I was just
eating [ __ ] clogged ass nose
that's rough yeah so the friendsgiving
was dope because I actually got to enjoy
it and I had energy
it was also sweat and [ __ ] bullets on
the Cowboys game you bet
no I did what oh yeah right right
fantasy yeah I [ __ ] Connor yeah yeah
right I took him out
I'm
I'm 3-0 and it's me and you this week
your toast I know because I also [ __ ]
my DJ set is on Thursday by the way you
guys are all invited oh thank you
Winston House Thursday night I'm DJing
and I have to think about my set so
that's what I'm gonna be really worried
about so I don't have like I can't wake
up in the morning be like okay fantasy
is a [ __ ] thing today no because I
can only ever like stress about one
thing at a time no you're gone that's
what I'm saying don't even try it and
I'm pissed I'm already researching
you're out
I got I already got my claims in your
toast I'm researching techno songs yeah
yeah you're toast I know you already got
your claims in yep what does that mean
that means like on Thursday morning then
the Wednesday yeah another day [ __ ] you
don't even know the day I'm [ __ ] you
got no time
this podcast review very racist five out
of five love listening to racist people
okay that's from last December sweet
they motivated me to unplug my
grandmother's ventilator and set up my
PC to mine crypto my superverse family
man dude her first family was almost a
year ago that was from January let's
watch it again
yeah
who did we show that to that was like I
thought we showed it to Ben in a meal
damn that has to be the next eight ball
yes they've not seen perversed let's do
it that's a [ __ ] HR game right there
great idea Luke Luke has to put on a
screen protector when he runs that
got sequel by now
that was a sequel I know that's saying
is it's a it's a franchise
they're on season three or four or five
for sure
oh dude